hey before we get into our show a big
thanks to magic the gathering arena for
sponsoring a portion of this video
magic the gathering arena is the digital
representation of the physical card game
that fans have enjoyed for over 25 years
it's a free-to-play download that
features turn-based tactical combat
creatures spells and artifacts
welcome to the challenge magic the
gathering arena makes it easier than
ever to learn
magic and gives players the tools they
need to become
masters learn core magic concepts
and hone your skills at your own pace
then contend right away unlocking
powerful decks just by playing come on
you know the game
now it's time to play now i don't know a
bulwark giant from a gideon black blade
but that's why it's so cool that the
color challenge tutorial
will teach you all the basics mtg arena
has a thorough tutorial mode to get you
up and running the game starts with five
full decks
corresponding to the five colors of
magic more cards and decks can be earned
as you level up
even in free unranked play mode try out
multiple game modes like
draft and brawl special in-game events
offer exciting prizes
and you could even be the next magic pro
with
esports qualifiers there is no better
time to start
playing play mtg arena for free
today check out more in the link below
and thanks to magic the gathering for
sponsoring this portion of this video
hey youtubers coming up on star talk my
interview with actress olivia munn
a geek superstar
now
[Music]
this is star talk i'm neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and host and we are
coming to you from my office at the
hayden planetarium
of the american museum of natural
history right here in new york city
co-host chuck knight hey chuck in the
house good to be in the cosmic crib
tweet oh sorry we hadn't called it that
in a while that's right that's what it
is that's what it is
it always will be the cosmic crib uh uh
tweeting at chuck nice comment thank you
sarah yes
all right and i got with me charles lou
the one and only
if charles lewis in the house you know
we're gonna do some geeking
yeah that's right looking forward to it
thank you thank you
so much because this topic today is
about
aliens and superheroes yes and we
we snared an interview with sort of
uh geek icon geek goddess
olivia munn yes i was out last time i
was out in l.a
i got an interview with her it was great
yeah just the whole universe of
uh mutant superheroes to be specific
well she is an x person
oh yeah because actually x-men are
mutants right here
i'm sorry in the age of apocalypse
that's correct okay there you go and
and it's a uh so she's been associated
with geek cultures
simply through her acting roles but
there's also some of that in her
because you know you don't have to be a
geek to be a geek actor but it helps
it does you want it to be true right
when someone has that kind of portfolio
it's better to be a fan of what you're
doing than just to do it in a mercenary
type way anyway that's a good point but
mercenary whoa
actor mercenary
and so she also wrote a memoir titled
suck it wonder woman misadventures
of a hollywood geek she's also a talk
show host
about geek culture and i had to ask her
because she's thought about i've thought
of it but we all thought about it but
she's like in it performing it yeah
is embodying it and i had to ask her
just
what in her mind defines being a geek
let's check it out there's a a misnomer
that
being a geek is just playing video games
or
or being awkward or just or having a
pile of
you know comic books you know i think
being a geek is
somebody that just thinks differently
than the rest of the crowd you know that
that it's not just what's laid out
before you there are different ways to
think about it and that's why
comic books have been so popular with
geeks for so long because
there is a group of people that operate
a different way
think a different way superheroes like
they are ostracized because of their
abilities to be different and i think
that all geeks
operate that way and we just we're just
going to oh so
superheroes never really fit in well
neither did the geek
set and i think that's what people
identify with i mean
when you're in school and your brain
works differently
and you're not picking it up on like
everybody else's
it's not that you're dumb it's that you
have to figure out a different way and
like
and that comes with you know when
whether people are autistic or on the
spectrum
or are shy or uncomfortable or socially
awkward or
really smart and clever and they could
be the college quarterback but also
be into astrophysics you know it's it's
just anybody who allows their brain to
think differently that's a movie title
the astrophysics quarterback
so charles you are star talks resident
geek in chief
i'm honored to be there i don't remember
who first knighted you that
it was it wasn't me i totally agree with
it but somebody upped that
right and it and and it landed on you
like
like bricks
so what was your arc through life to
become the geek in chief that you are
for me geekdom we have to ask chuck
did a football quarterback ever give you
a wedgie because you were just so geeked
out
okay because he went to a school full of
geeks
astrophysics quarterbacks are perfectly
reasonably acceptable we at stanford
i didn't go to stanford okay uh no the
the
idea of smart athletes is not at all
contradictory no it isn't so many
intelligent athletes just as
there are very i don't know and it's not
a new concept bill bradley
yeah was uh uh wasn't he wrote he's a
road scholar
senator and a center and played for the
new york knicks back the last time they
won any kind of championship
right speaking of stanford um what's his
name uh who's a great cornerback and he
plays for the san francisco 49ers you
mean sherman
yeah sherman richard sherman he is uh an
extremely
smart guy and uh there are many many
intelligent players okay except
you never did any athletics so we have
to go
not on the varsity line no okay no we
had fun but we didn't so in your arc
do you would you agree with her sense of
this yes
geekdom is essentially freedom from
the norm from the constraints
of social or familial or other kinds of
pressures
but we generally associate comic books
video games
but also attendance at comic-con yes
these are kind of
these are kind of card carrying
behaviors yes but they're also theater
geeks they're art geeks they're
opera geeks they're music there are
science geeks
all kinds of things when you are just
different
then you become a geek in the eyes of
many and then you have to ask yourself
what are you going to do
with it i myself fortunately
had such a strong sense of self some
people might say arrogance or egotism
that i didn't care what other people
sounds like he went to therapy and they
trying to get that through to him sound
like that doesn't it
yeah so i didn't really care that i was
off to the side
of what was supposedly mainstream yes i
was bummed at times when i felt excluded
or otherwise not
part of the in-crowd but i was fortunate
that i did have
a few good friends who were like me who
were
interested in the same kinds of things
that i was so that i did not have a
problem
with a social group that made me feel
comfortable
and as a result my geekdom gave me
freedom you found family
i did okay so now but geek to me should
also
mean not just an interest in something
but some expertise
yeah you could put on the table so you
can throw that you know more about it
than your average person so chuck you i
i like you as my co-host because you
you hang with the geek folk so i think
you got some geek underbelly
from the your past that you have not
fessed up about i lived most of my life
as a closeted geek
oh and then believe it or not 10 years
ago when i started working with you is
when i came out of the closet
i felt like you know i was like you know
what why am i
hiding this part of myself
liberation i was liberated but as a
matter of fact i could say like you know
what yeah i really enjoyed this i love
science i love all this stuff
neil yeah you can express it
professionally
correct yeah and for the most part i was
the guy
that you know i knew everybody but at
the same time when you talk to me
you were you would be like oh this guy
really needs some help because i wanted
to talk about
you know whatever i was reading at the
time mm-hmm and a lot of people didn't
they
you know a lot of people weren't even
reading they weren't right exactly a lot
of my friends weren't so it turns out
that they were the ones that needed the
help
to be honest you could have helped them
understand the beauty and the amazing
things that you were reading at the time
which they felt like they couldn't
express or do
because of whatever constraints they
felt part of
uh yeah i'm gonna go yeah what you said
it's perfect
whatever you said that's right that's
exactly what i meant
so charles what's the next geek frontier
is it
because it tends to track technology yes
it is is it like vr worlds
is it augmented reality you know what
with video games
so far so good this sounds great the
geeks tend to be at the
moving frontier absolutely of how
technology applies to
ways to not
go to work i believe the next great geek
frontier
at least right now is biohacking
really i think wait wait wait wait wait
biohacking biohacking the idea of like
say
uh someone is paralyzed and can't move
their arm because their nerve systems
nervous systems can't get from their get
signals from their brain to their arm
instead you put a say a wireless thing
up against your temple
which then allows you to do some other
way of communicating maybe through
5g maybe through some sort of wireless
or bluetooth signal
6g right at that point at that point
yeah at some point
uh which then allows that person to move
the arm so you have
completely convinced me that you've
watched too many science fiction movies
well
this is the point on this helmet and
then you become let's see
you asked me what the frontier was and
that's what it is and we're not talking
about like
cyborg terminators or anything we're
talking about people whose lives can be
improved
um but that's not just a geek frontier
that's a medical
frontier that doesn't matter just geeks
i don't know there are people who are
right now
just geeks who can do cool things with
you know a screwdriver and a webcam they
might
lead the charge to make this happen i
think there's some neat stuff i don't
think there's gonna be talking about
like people
inserting you know devices into their
gray matter or anything like that i'm
talking about like half of every episode
of black mirror just a little just a
little bit too crazy
right exactly right i'm not talking
about that kind of thing i'm talking
about the other kinds
there's also uh biohacking in
agriculture
growing plants called gmo geometrically
modification
so but i really like when what you said
that geeks
are people that don't fit in because
they have interest that they want to
preserve within themselves
and not succumb to social pressure
so olivia also had thoughts about this
about what it is to think differently
growing up especially
when you have peer pressure in school
let's check it out i'm half asian
so you know there is a very strict like
you know
uh grade system like there's like the
asian f is a b so
so it was like i and i am so in my
opinion really true
it's 100 true and so i remember had to
work
so hard to understand because it was
just going so fast and i just i needed
more time to absorb it
um in fact i got really good at cheating
because of it
like i had to learn when i was like
really young i had a i had to learn like
how to come up with a little system of
um of like
dots or dashes like on my notebook or on
a chalkboard or whatever so i would see
like the formulas everywhere because you
couldn't
have them out but i would like sketch
them into like little dots and i would
come up with a whole
like an alphabet based on dots and
dashes just because that's how my brain
had to work i was it was so much easier
to come up with that than to just
learn the actual formula it was easier
for me to learn a whole new
like system this is the beginnings of
cryptography right yeah yeah
i mean it but it's it worked for the way
my brain worked and
um but there was mr theck and that was
in eighth grade
i was 13 and i remember um
there was a time where he called and he
said look you're um your daughter's
flunking
honors algebra and my mom
was normally a yeller but she
sits me down and i was like oh my gosh
normally she's like the screaming ellie
but it's
that moment she knew it was more serious
and she sat down she says okay so you're
making
an f right now in algebra and i was like
oh gosh
and she said and now i asked him what
would it take for you to make an a
because obviously that's it's either a
or nothing
and she said he said you have to make
100 on every
quiz test pop quiz and homework and all
the bonuses on all of those
for the rest of the semester and i was
like well there's just no way i'm doing
i mean
i was like literally calling you know
the funeral home i was like i need a
casket
asap this is not gonna end well and my
mom said you're gonna do it
and every day i would come home and
she'd say did you do your homework and i
said yes and she says
let's do it again like oh i don't and
she would normally like when we would be
studying and stuff she'd be like no it's
this this you'd yell
this time this whole period of time my
mom was just just took her time with me
a little more tender yeah and and she
understood that i was trying
but that i needed someone to just
explain it
slowly and in a different way and
by the end of it i made an a i made 100
on every single
quiz test pop quiz homework plus the
bonuses and
i mean so that that's what has helped me
in my life now and i think
something seems hard or don't understand
it i will say
to myself i know i can do i just need to
stop down and think about how my brain
works
charles you're on sabbatical right now
but otherwise you actively teach
at the college of staten island yes yes
city university of new york yes what do
you
how do you handle people who learn
differently
or at the college level do you have the
luxury to not care yeah
because they paid they just could learn
or get out here's the information get it
how you get it good
you always have the option to not care
but i wouldn't be
in what i'm doing in my field if i
didn't care
and you have trouble with that well
thank you
let me first shout out give a shout out
to young olivia
for getting through that really
difficult period of time academically
and a shout out to olivia's mom
for doing exactly the kind of thing that
i would have done
in the circumstances there if i were
enlightened enough to do so so she
knew there's a point where yelling is
not going to work so we need to go to
plan b
yeah right okay so now what about the
fact that
we always hear that some people just
can't handle math
what what do you do about that what you
do is you realize
that these people cannot handle math
class
they cannot handle math curriculum or
math
teaching or math tests but isn't
and that's what we find out right we all
are excellent mathematicians
we just have varying degrees of ability
to look at something in an abstract form
and then write it down on a piece of
paper because somebody else told us to
right our calculation abilities on a
regular basis are remarkable our
geometry in order to walk or to run
our physics what people often talk about
and
by the way obviously professional
players do this best but anyone can do
it
okay if i throw you a ball and it's not
where you're standing
you will run to it and arrive where the
ball will land
as you catch it right most people will
do this successfully that's right
all right which means you're there's a
calculation calculation
right there's a parabolic dark and it's
it speeds up as it come down
you're going to intersect it at the
right time and at the right place
so so the human brain is capable of
doing math and i don't care who you are
you can do it
the best thing for me to do when i see
this in my son is
to read and then to listen to it
multiple so it comes input yes different
sensory
sensors that's what i do when i give a
public talk really because they say are
you gonna stand behind the podium
right no no i'm gonna walk around i'm
gonna use my body gestures and
and and tap in some damage drives the
camera people crazy
yeah they hate it but i don't i'm not
doing
and so what do you think about her dot
system is is that cheating
or is it um yeah that's cheating yes
come on
and by the way i i had some news for her
uh there is a system that's been
invented it's called morse code
she could have just learned that yeah
but she was a kid right right no
cheating is a fascinating
you know concept bending the rules i
mean how many of us
have never watched a movie online
without paying for it
or downloaded a song to hear it without
going through the proper copyright
right all of us have found something
some rule that they found onerous or
they'd rather
circumvent and then gotten around it
well also too it's a it's whatever
sometimes you're more motivated to cheat
for her she had pressure to perform
yeah i almost don't even blame her yeah
that pressure to perform she's like i'm
going to get killed if i don't
you know believe me that's a that's a
lot of pressure i've been there too much
yeah
too much for some reason i wasn't good
at geometry because i didn't go
and
and so okay you know um but there was a
guy
i'll tell you when i when when i got
good at geometry
when when steve i forget steve's last
name he was like no man you cannot see
my paper
and that was it i was like oh yeah that
was the end i was like damn i got to get
this
and i went home and i was like i need a
tutor
problem there you go all right when we
come back more of my interview with
olivia munn
and we get into mutants and superpowers
when star talk returns
we're back star talk we are talking
about superheroes
of the mutant kind and we got
charles liu who is our geek in chief yes
talking about superheroes yes absolutely
and so
we olivia munn yes she
was in one of the x-men movies yes she
played psylocke in age of apocalypse
save psylocke x-men apocalypse cylic
p-s-y
l-o-c-k-e and she even did her own
stunts
in the fight scenes i don't know if you
knew that i didn't know that
yeah yeah so let's get a little bit of
insight into this appearance in that
film
as we rejoin my interview with actress
olivia munn
so you do martial arts is that right
yeah what kind taekwondo we grew up
doing taekwondo all five kids we had to
again it's
we have to play a musical instrument and
we have to make a's and we have to
that my mom and kick some ass yes well
your character in
x-men kicks serious ass
not just with your this blade thing that
comes out what's the
is there a word for that it's a psionic
sword psionic sword
yeah so psylocke her ability is to be
able to create anything with her mind
in my opinion she has always been the
most powerful because if you can create
anything with your mind
there you go done game over right right
the reason why
silac doesn't just create a boulder and
just shut the whole thing down because
she could
is because when you have in my opinion
when you have a power
that great you get a little bored and
it's so much more fun and intimate to
kill with a sword because you have to
get up close
and i had to as a fan when i watch
i if people have super human powers
i want them i want i want to be violent
and i want them to tear each other apart
like that's really what i
and these kind of movies i want to see
what it would be like if you have these
powers what would it really be
tell me about the powers in the x-men
universe all right well psylocke
specifically was the sister of captain
britain
the the captain britain and the various
uh british marvel comics
in the 80s were very much favored by
american
collectors back then who were older than
the children's crowd because they
weren't
controlled as much by the comics code
authority you know that
had to keep everything all
family-friendly and things like that
they meaning the uk the uk centers
freedom right they had
they had more freedom and the uns did
not and so this
character betsy braddick actually was
originally psylocke
uh a an intelligent person who also had
powers of uh
telepathy telekinesis things like that
eventually came and joined the x-men
and was there for a while but then
around 1989 or so
marvel changed the character
dramatically
first they gouged her eyes out and then
they added cybernetic eyes
and then she was brought over to uh i
think hong kong somewhere in asia
brainwashed by an assassination team
called the hand
and then she became the seriously scary
kick-ass character so
her why do you know this much about
psychology
so olivia mum wasn't too far off the
block so so
why do you know this much about this i
know that's that's an inordinate
information about a c-level character
in the marvel university that's amazing
well charles yes charles yes
i i don't i don't i'm sorry it's just a
thing i don't know who you are
that's pretty cool but what happened was
that transformation
did turn psylocke from sort of a c-level
character
to a very popular marvel character
that's it because then she had this sort
of
hard edge to her right which became very
popular
amongst they were doing that we're
starting to read comics much more than
the teens and the children that were
reading it beforehand
so that dark sharpness
that olivia was describing in the clip
is
very much reflected in the current
psylocke which has the ability
not just to read minds and so forth but
actually
creating remind energy so there's others
magneto
yes professor x wolverine that's a lot
of people's favorite
oh yeah and cyclops cycles
storms i kind of like storms controls
the weather storm was kind of cool
yes go way back nothing like a
meteorologist
that has superpowers looks like storms
yes
no looks great oh yeah
so chuck what would you do if you had if
you had her ability
psylocke's ability psylocke what would
you make
listen first of all that's not the only
like
the idea of creating something with your
mind green lantern has the same thing
it's just the power is in the ring
but whatever he thinks of comes into
existence in an energy
form so i mean it's not i i don't like
that power did it just mix two different
universes
yes yes you know that's that's a
that's a no no a punishable crime yes
although there have been some famous
crossovers over time there was a batman
versus the hulk
there was a spider-man versus superman
there were some
really good ones the teen titans teen
titans and the x-men the x-men
in the 1980s but my
power would be like
um sebastian shaw that's what i would
like to be like
he's a guy that can absorb any
energy any energy blow up
set off a hydrogen bomb
and guess what he can absorb that isn't
this what
what what the material is that was
featured in
in black panther yes exactly
vibranium does that right it's
essentially living vibration he's living
vibrating living vibrations
living to me that's what i would want
that's the power i would want
because then no matter no matter what
the like for instance you could
throw me into the sun itself and i
could take that that
nuclear reaction and turn it into
something i could use so let me cross
into a third universe so
in star wars yes the force awakens the
death star had extra powers because it
sucked all the energy out of a star
then it could blow up multiple planets
star killer you mean yeah
right but apparently they didn't do the
math because they said now we have more
power we can
kill six planets instead of one but if
you add up how much power is in a star
you can kill ten thousand planets right
so they didn't do the math because it
could have been a way better weapon
than even was shown in the in the movie
sweet but they had nothing to do with
with x-men here
so we digress yes
still good to know so i so there's her
character
yes olivia munn's character can create
materialize anything with her mind
i asked her if she could choose her own
superpower
what would it be let's check it out
interesting
it has to be to fly i mean if you i mean
you're an astrophysicist
so if you could have any power in the
world what would you have
uh it would be to read people's minds
interesting and what would you do with
that
you would know before someone committed
a crime that that's what they were about
to do
so you don't have to beat them up you
can just prevent them from doing
minority report
for example although that's a little
creepier the way how they
create but my point is you would stop
them yeah
there they are in the act of committing
a crime then you have to fight them and
then drag them to prison
or you know they're about to and then
what do you do well you
you say hey look come over here let's go
have a cup of coffee
you know it wouldn't make a good movie
but do you think that worked with do you
think hitler just needed a cup of coffee
do you think hitler were just waiting
for neil to come through like hey
hey come here let's go to the beer
garden
um yeah so but so that is an interesting
thing so that way you don't have to be
strong
you can be you could be
intimately clever about how to distract
someone from whatever might have been
their nefarious
plan that is awesome
degrasse tyson is java man
please don't tell me yes please don't
wreck new york
hey buddy let's talk about
that's great actually it's a great idea
like some madagascar cinnamon on the top
so chuck what superpower do you think
you would have you want superpowers
that's a great question
at one time i thought that maybe i would
want the same superpower as you was
thinking
you know being able to read minds but
then i found out
that most thoughts are never realized
yes
thousands of thoughts there's a whole
episode of the twilight
zone on that very fact yeah every time
we read a book we have new thoughts
every time we imagine something new
thoughts
the only things that actually matter are
what come out in the real world we
cannot
like in like minority port or other
kinds of environments castigate someone
for their thoughts
as long as they don't act upon them as a
reason but they had good data that went
since the crime rate did drop right that
they were actually getting people who
would have committed the crime and they
always waited for them to be in the act
of committing the crime before they
exactly they did they didn't rest you in
your bed right right so
that episode of the twilight zone yes
someone some coin
was spun and it ended up standing up on
its end and that changed the universe
and he could hear people's thoughts and
he went into the
bank and the bank guard
was thinking after everyone leaves i can
enter the safe because the safe will be
unlocked
i can open the thing and he said my god
she's like alerting the police and
everything
and then he finds out the bank guard
this is back when banks had guards by
the
way
okay the bank guard has those thoughts
every day right yeah this is a reason
fantasy right and so you don't you can't
distinguish
their fantasy from their whatever they
would actually exactly so
i agree with you thanks thanks so my
desired power is instead to be able to
know
exactly the right thing to say or do
at any given moment towards what end
toward either peace love and happiness
either making someone feel better or
stopping something bad from happening
or isn't that my cup of joe yes that is
that's that's
the same power it's the same idea but
instead of talking about
weren't going to commit a crime
you were going to commit a crime you
would have got to scout him
so so preventing crime with actions
rather than thoughts yes
okay very good chuck how about you oh
man
you know i'm not see you guys are too
damn thoughtful i just want to be able
to vaporize people
with your eyes it's been done it's
called cyclops
oh yeah i guess so i guess so all right
so charles what do you think
science can do to create a superpower oh
actual you know real points so you know
we have the iron man suit first
that comes closest to wow there are now
cybernetic suits
yeah they're not nearly powered by you
know some arc generator or whatever but
it's certainly you can move or be
protected from things
what about genetic mutations yep
genetically mutate you
so that what so that you don't catch
diseases that are otherwise lethal
okay it's not superpower yeah that
that's just being healthy
puts a superpower in the jungles of
africa but if it's true for any disease
then you become immortal then that's a
superpower
no but it's not a superpower if everyone
has it we learned that in the
incredibles
why not it is it's still what's the
mantra if
if everyone is special no no then no one
is special no
i disagree with superpower it's just
power well
see that's a a small-minded
interpretation of what superpower truly
is
right you just call me smallmouth no no
no i'm talking meet me outside
you see how small-minded i am if
i'm saying your mama is special and so
is everybody
else that's hilarious yes no no this is
a very pollyanna-ish idea of what being
special means and so on
but the idea that we can all benefit
from something
and therefore be super as a result is
not at all an alien or a bad concept
i i have no problem with for example
everybody
being able to live as long as they'd
like to live in a healthy manner
that is a true superpower is it not yeah
but it's also
um you know a big-time fantasy because
like what what kind of taxation on the
earth would that create
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so remember what arthur c clarke
said right not only was he a great
science fiction writer but he also
patented for example the communication
satellite so very intelligent engineer
and scientist
he said and i paraphrase i think
that any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic yes
yes right and if you're just a
paraphrase that's a quote
i got it oh i think you got it okay okay
so
so if uh magic is essentially a
superpower
right being a wizard is super powerful
or supernatural or something
then that means all of us who have the
technology they don't know how to wield
it
and how to create it just yeah it just
looks like it just looks like it
right but theoretically neither is the
iron man armor
right i know what you're saying right
i'm 100
right yeah that's my take okay all right
when we come back
we devote an entire segment
to olivia's cosmic queries
awesome because you know she has some
i'm sure oh yeah you know
oh yeah right so when we come back like
what's your favorite coffee
kona from the side slope the eastern
slopes of the
star talk returns more of my interview
with olivia money
we're back star talk featuring my
interview with
patron saint of geeks
olivia munn all right yeah she had a
actress
you know she's got good street cred for
being a geek
and in this final segment i just thought
why don't i see if she has questions
for me about the universe because you
know she's a deep thinker
and she think thought about this stuff
so let's get her first question for me
right now i want to know if you think
that aliens exist i have no reason to
doubt
that the galaxy in the universe isn't
teeming with aliens
so it makes me so happy that you said
that but it's not it's not because i
want it to be true no because the
science shows you that right science
is compelling when you look at what
we're made of as
as life on earth humans we've made the
same ingredients
in rank order as what the universe is
made of
so the fact that life started here on
earth
there's no reason to think that was some
special occasion
some special thing and now we have
catalogs of
exoplanets that is growing into the
multiple thousands now and that's just
in our little
little sector of our entire galaxy
one of countless billions of galaxies in
the universe
to say that we are alone in the universe
there is no that's inexcusably
egocentric
to think such a thing i agree
so chuck why do you think people get so
excited maybe people like olivia but
maybe
others are excited at the prospect that
aliens are out there rather than
scared i think well maybe they're two
camps there's a scared camp and the
happy camp
yes i think there are two camps uh but i
think that being alone
makes this so incredibly random
and worthless i think that's really from
a philosophy i think it's more
philosophical than anything else
you know we don't want to be that
special we don't want to be that special
you know because that really does it's
you know
it it does make this whole thing so
random and worthless that it almost
doesn't count
so charles what do you think of the
chances that we are unique in the
universe
uh zero zero zero statistically speaking
the chances that we are unique
are zero but well wait wait let me back
well back up
let me back up so that's my finger
so earth spent billions of years
to create us featuring a single cell
life right and then billions more with
interesting life but still by today's
standards simple
okay so the life we think of as complex
and intelligent and all that is a
very recent phenomenon yes in the tree
of life
and it's only happened in one branch of
the tree of life the vertebrates
and the intelligence we think of is even
in sub-branches of that
the mammals of the vertebrate of the
tree of life right okay so
so the contingency of that suppose
something happened on earth uh-huh
way back that just snipped at that
frequency
snipped the vertebrae chain you would
never have the apes you would never have
the hominids you would never have the
humans
and you just have everything else so i'm
not asking you
do you think it's obvious there's life
elsewhere i'm asking you do you think
we could be alone in our intelligence
wow
every species that has ever existed or
will
exist is unique in its own way yep
so which is what unique means
i have no rebuttal to that right i'm
just you know and what that means
merriam-webster here but i'm just saying
in that particular vein
there is no other species like us
anywhere ever
right right but if you want to compare
ourselves to
any possible aliens that have some
that have something like intelligence
that we can recognize
that has a backbone or a spine like we
recognize
or some other kind of combination
or permeability or even intelligence
without an invertebrate intelligence
then
so you're right you don't have to have a
backbone to have intelligence
because we got squid so the octopus is
by most measures an intelligent creature
so if you
if you draw your boundaries in a way to
say
is there life that we would recognize as
intelligent and communicative and so
forth
the odds of that happening are
essentially 100 cool
all right i got a question for both of
you yeah but are they going to be able
to do uh
uh the pythagorean theorem yeah well
math is really yeah
if they don't have a backbone why would
they need to do the pythagorean theorem
i don't even know how you get that
sentence
if if you're a super intelligent
octopoid
uh species and you're zipping around the
universe
why do you need hard angles
oh
that's right why not just have fluid uh
boundaries
exactly fluid fluid boundary and it is
well known even with our limited
intelligence that relies on geometry and
hard boundaries that there
are non-euclidean geometries that do not
rely on say
all the triangles adding up 100
communities things like that
i think there's a lot of potential that
none of us have even thought about if
anything i know we got to move on but i
want to ask you guys this
and she's kind of based not really
how much do you think that we know since
you're talking about how if there's life
in the universe
yeah what would you say is from uh one
to ten using decimal places if you want
what is the amount of knowledge that we
actually have with respect to
what is knowledge that exists one half
really between zero and ten one half
between zero and ten one half
oh between zero and ten one hat yeah
neil is speaking i thought you meant one
half all the way to zero like that would
be a five but two
no no no no no no no no no wait wait no
i have no yeah
0.5.5 you know why why because
go ahead because dark matter and dark
energy
we have no idea of what those are and
they comprise 96
of what is driving this universe all
right that's a very good so on a scale
of one to ten
we know half basically neil is being
generous
even in the part the 0.5 out of 10 right
that we know about in terms of
protons neutrons electrons neutrinos all
the familiar stuff
that you know we still know
less than one percent of what's actually
going on
in our observable universe alone so in
the stuff that we actually know we still
do we still don't know that's right and
the stuff that we know so i feel like
we're at 0.01
of 0.5 all right charles can't you give
us a little
man i'm not saying that's a bad thing
i'm saying that
the fact that we've learned that much
just being on a little mud ball here in
the middle of the
solar system man he's in a distant mode
you know what i just see now an alien
race showing up here
people of the mud bomb
and i would stand up to that alien say
and what
right because it's really neat that we
have such humble
origins from a scientific biological
point of view and yet we still
understand so much already and we can't
wait to learn more
all right okay here's why i think it's
not that bad okay all right
sure and i think i can convince you
because we have similar
brain wirings we train the same sort of
things i think i got him here
okay he doesn't he doesn't know what's
coming all right all right you ready
bring it on
in the history of
civilization before science
up to the modern methods and tools of
science into
modern day uh
things would happen in the world
that we wouldn't understand and so you
invent gods
you invent the god of the gaps yeah the
gods are the gaps
then and gaps implies you knew stuff to
the left or right of it there were not
even
gaps everything was explained this way
all right
as we moved on things would get
explained it was no longer a mystery
other things would show up oh that's you
know what is that this lightning coming
from
you know moving through the air what is
that oh it's electricity it's got
electrons it's it
all right we got that all right what is
this thing it moves a needle on a
that's a magnetic field so now we got
that oh
by the way they're two sides of the same
coin electromagnetism
all right we got that uh what else oh
the atoms are behaving weirdly
oh let's discover quantum physics and
now we can explain that
all right and so my point is
how much today is in our world
experience
that's a phenomenon that completely
defies explanation
ah this is my point yes because you make
an excellent point see i told you
yeah right yeah right when faraday
passed a wire through a magnetic field
and a meter move
that's mysterious oh my gosh we have to
figure out a way to explain this
and we did right we understood
electricity and faraday laid the
till the soil for all of the later
understanding of electricity to unfold
including the efforts of um was partly
based on what
um benjamin franklin our boy was able to
write he has a
book called experimental researchers
into electricity yeah
all right so i'm asking today
are there things moving and we don't
understand what's making it happen
is there some force operating that
defies our account
so you're saying that the reduction in
the number of mysteries yes
something's moving right something's
making it move and we don't
understand what that is so the forces of
nature
which we've condensed down to just four
operations
in this world the strong force the weak
force um
gravity and electromagnetic forces that
accounts
for all of this right okay yes we still
don't know dark matter dark energy
that's a big unknown but that's i'm
prepared to limit our unknown to that
right now
and i'm not gonna go down to down that
hole with you fair enough
i i can accept you because you're just
looking at me and nodding whoa
but your idea is sound and i can see how
you can defend the position that you've
taken
very good yeah excellent very good
excellent all right so olivia had one
last question for me
all right in this interview and it had
to do
with invoking science to make sense of
the world
let's check it out do you know when
people talk about
um like planets like oh when the moon
comes in and it affects people this way
or when mercury is in retrograde
people will say oh mercury's in
retrograde that's why they're like late
or they're i've noticed
yeah and they say that a lot do you
believe that the planets
affect us individually so you can
measure like how much light is coming
from a planet or how much gravity
you would feel from it so you can
measure this
so let's take for example let's say
you're about to give birth
and there's mars in view
oh you're born under mars
well you can calculate how much more
light
is coming to the delivery table from the
lamp
relative to mars well it's hundreds of
thousands of times the intensity of
light
what about the gravity from mars i can
calculate that
we've known this since isaac newton how
to calculate that
and you calculate it and you learn that
the gravitational
field of the midwife
or the medical doctor who is helping you
deliver the baby
is greater than the gravitational force
from mars on you and your soon to be
born child
so if you're to appeal to mars you're
gonna have to say oh there's something
scientists have yet to discover
about it but you can't talk about the
light you can't talk about the gravity
because we got that okay so now you have
to say
that some mysterious thing that's
affecting us that scientists have yet
to measure okay
well we have five senses five
traditional senses
some people say they have a sixth sense
they can know what someone is thinking
or know
something that they don't otherwise have
direct access to
i don't have a problem with people
saying they have success
what i can tell you however as a
scientist
i have access to dozens of senses
what is science if not there is
something to be measured in this world
that my human physiology
has no clue what it is or how it works
and i've built this machine
that can tell you it's there you'd have
to say there was something going on
between you and mars
that all of my access to my dozens of
senses
cannot measure and it does make sense
understanding that when people want to
blame other things and that's a big part
of it that's why you see a lot of people
who believe in all this stuff
where their lives are still just like
they're all anxiety induced and that you
know you're like well
clearly it's not making things more
peaceful for you because they've just
got something else to blame it on
they've got something
they have not taken control of them yeah
that that's the truth
yep good stuff it's the gap
that they're trying to explain using
scientific language like
mercury and retrograde but it's not
actually science that's just
pseudoscience
right but so i guess the point is the
power of science
to explain what you think is a
phenomenon uh is extraordinary yes
amazingly so and people who don't even
understand it or don't know about it
will
use it even incorrectly because it helps
explain the unknown
hmm so we need some parting thoughts
chuck do you have anything deep to share
with us deep no
oh trust me you're putting too much
pressure on me so chuck we need some
particles do you have anything shallow
to share
absolutely no i i just really appreciate
the fact that
um olivia is a person who is
scientifically curious
and you know i think the more that
people in entertainment show that side
of themselves
the more we might see a reflection of
that in society
charles how about you hooray for olivia
munn
for not only embracing who she is
as a geek but also recognizing
that she learns differently and that she
is different from others and yet she
embraces all those things
owns them and says here i am just like
the title of her book suck it wonder
woman
right she is great in her own way
and it doesn't really matter what people
are going to compare her to
because she's cool just as she is and
only wonder woman hates her
i don't know that i can add to what the
two of you just
shared uh what i will say is it's a
reminder
that
if
try when you're growing up and you don't
quite know who you are yet
or what you want to be emotionally
personally
professionally and
what is going on around you they're
social forces oh yeah to homogenize you
into what others would have you become
and what that does is it robs you of
your individuality
when you do such a thing so true and
so much of what has shaped this world
has been via the expression of
individuality
yes so imagine what this world would be
today
if everyone were afforded the
opportunity
to not have to comply
with social forces imagine how diverse
in in the expression of intellect
this world would be imagine how much
more fun
the world would be yeah and i think
olivia
munn is a best example of that
who's entered a field that previously
never really embraced
who we are as geeks and she's taken it
right to the camera lens
and i i agree with you charles it's
someone to applaud
yes and let there be
many more olivia muns yes well said to
grace the screen
absolutely all right you've been
watching listening
you've been consuming star talk
uh our edition on uh superheroes with
some cinnamon on top
with with some madagascar sentiment i
just want to thank olivia munn
for uh giving us that interview and
charles liu always good to have you
thank you so much yes sir you're my man
you got it all right i'm neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist as
always
fitting you
you